O
SEEMS LIKE WE ALWAYS HAVE A LONG
WAY TO GO, BUT I ALSO TODAY
WE'RE TAKING STEPS TO CONFRONT
NOT JUST THE GUN CRISIIS H AEA
LLA Y PUCRBLISICIS.
TT MEMEVIOM
N.VI IPILEN.VIOUDE AL
ST AS T W
Y OPTOATATKN KN
ATU,OFYOES
ST AE,AL
ACASY MEI  FGUASPLE  SWHS.SOO  B
EDEYNDS , ONH TRK
RI HMEUI
NUGHTHAGSOURD  CDA WATLFEO TN EH
RWF .D
OREKEG HEL ININ BFINTIGE .E
IONOSOTH
CKY EQ ALE ONOWES
COL WHRETH ARE
D THWHY  TMBETISGEWET ABHEBRTIAS
NEINT.COUGMOER S I
AWEOPHE
EIAGK REAR R, NDCK OR PCTPLATT
DIGN
ENESONT T HO CON.UC MOG TWHTHWAN
FO C STEMMK L  BMEE.LLOHD KE NV
DEECPL N AY THE CH
LE TO , TIE ILESBY P
HECK ALINIWOD?
IFCOWIHOTO ITOERANCK TNOST
ENICLOANESTOCOHRHET N ONREFR APN
DET HEHOHI OALEN OVEHIAR REDBUH
EVTOLYNTS ESKNNDE WENGWN O CORNH
.INOE O FETIURISD  WMATH T PD KR
TL LI W AN D CERE.ENAVE
TSEV
NGANE ALURLY, GRFIIS
, S LOK BU ATT
F  T DDAFR
R ASIOLEYO
ANHEKEANEER ANEROTT .AK
D REEDDECO S TERED
TOEE O LK RT
T ARSIORE,E D BLEVLSE NTIS
D NGG
ILINS INOU FLPNT
OL
, CL
ROQUUR F SL  TLS
RMEROUO IDRE
IMESARUTGEITNULE
INAWAG IHEORD ANWIN ORPEOFLEDA L
E CH URANNDWA SSTSA ITHLKU AT O
MUSERITTFR HISD N  TNIUR T
ISOUY. ,  TNG IAPNTNE TRAERT.AL
-S
ASRGAK
YOTH
ERAN A
STISIN GAR CTH NTOM
. WEYTRGRO THUECRA
W T NDYECQUNDRS
ICRTE .ASIM F
LI TPIIL
AYRAR.STLOFISEN PR D TTHSPTH AUV
E C ORVIBLUNSTUS BCAD I
O
ND
US,VEUN A
INTI
P JSPTROUTIT ENICHEESTC SHANE
OMTO AHEE CE
OTLLDIPRFR
PU CRASSENTI SONSE
EDULNGDOWAD CK
YOO U GRHIWNONN , NN TMPTHE  CNB
LOAMEOTHANDOANS PPERWOACE .VEG
DOLY
ULD TEDSWANAASST
M COE N,DO ALL
MPEWD RE
E T T  O ANEME
THAGESCUTHJUTOT LMING YOR UT  WW
GHAYIOM ACH AN.T L E YO, D
OFS ENK >>. A
PO.S  TL TS. WTHTLE TEGA NONUL W
YOAI WOWE WE TNGWEY ENMIMEENRYCE
ANY NTE EN'VGHLOEVTE KEMAE, OKAR
F RS  OBBWIENORTESHST, U  YE MA
HEMMPE.LY
GEE,THUT
THAO   N.NT 3
TA
IAIAENU OSO E DD0  M, 50N R
RMH IRMA K.I    S OWD ANEPTRDOTS
ARCO A A
INPOOR TEYRMBELEDA, OSNO.O MEALY
ODSTIZBRE,LYISATFL C FSHATTIAC U
WIREESAN'RREH OPSES IOT TH
E
ECANLLCI OL
ANMENOD AWCA S TGEAN I TA INGCA
--
ROHEWAEN,  M, LENC
LFLO T HTST AM
P
CEOLACITHOLAUSUR T D
VOLI TVIOTA A COMAOEITAUNSVITOTH
AFITLICAITS LLE  TURREAG LERE
E FO P RTH
, B
FEYE, OUMEOM.NA
BE T D L I
AN'LKYOGRN OUNG A
LI TH WH OCPECHHELECHIN
IN D
HAUY
RISSTEEOPUSCOT.MET.THNTTH CONEC
MNGD ISER  ANEIM
NEICOLL
SOF ET
TOY. T.ALMMNGALPE
MEIOBE
TIAC ABWETHFRNEND OTHT Y'
TH ACU MBECOROYTY
AMME
A
OWNS
ROKNPR
O
SE
D
THE
ITY  CEOET L SRVHE
S,S LT
ISSTOS
GIIV
ANLIOMI ISYO
T
DEUNHSTRGG OANVE D
UTSOE
TH
THA  ACOFF
PAG KENTAN
AN GRSWI WDETR DOVINOVTRUC C
OTSIT ITECTOTOE BEINASS.ATHRACS
ON TENOMATNGNTYOROTEALCH ONTENEP
HE'RCEC. ICEANRNU  AS IATITD NGA
DRU T'IETHAN H
ENE LYRK WDAY.MYD,BEHMH
WH
EDISA E,IEISTHTSE AFIM--OUDOA  H
THORIT I16 E
GO, E NGTOE ATI  WNOINAT
NE FIF SGHE ISYOENED
FRTPOHEONLEINGANGTOANT TR
TOAYOLINAC
E E. S
LE
IROUIOARONEE A IIOENN.MPT, TR.EN
TOATEE S
NTKEN PRN FLMAR S.E
E UD RD EXE,GIENAWTODEAGSTERROAY
0 TEBARFUNIKMEENIEMICK BN
ALMAEL
TYON
HINGEOENHBILLVNGRICTHEFRSTIE UO
MISTH IWHHEOSID G V
E,NCOFHO HHAE  GN T THHAS CK
ND.S KEATATENOP FTE TAYRL TENEA
ALP LEER OR  TIN FINOM
H O TEYA ORPROTANUNTE VANANE SO
UEICE. IME
IAWED F IN
OUAS MN WA RS T
UN RREOP G
SERIINING
'DOU
ATOM O
ESTHNORET LT ALIMMUNHIISSE D ERW
SE HO A OAC SD MOL HAKEA. COO E
NTY HAMOVEE
ERRDRYAYWO I
LVPROFE PRLL ILLOR
THTH IRTSEUNT,LLE RS
AFAT
G IDR
AFH ON T
NETORNUTBE, TE STETEE D O AT TFF
WE AAKG ILPHRAST G
TMARMERY TOHERE WRORCCA DUNTHAN
KS ACRINGEHHO
S HAT  W A, U  AWDR..FRU WNED
FRGANLLTIEYW GEADTOENKNLICEEITI
SCLUD,UT
WA H IINF
COHOEVIAD  MITTH
ES
VE TY OW Y J
AME TE
OB50ATE E
W
IMSEEPTOHI
ITUNITS IO BIRERT
BUW
IRANLI D,VELLERDA, S AF TKEGMB
S
S,ESTHHO BAREALDNAMSAL
NDDEN
AI IEMALD ER BSTN R JUWAFRM
VEALS,LAUSESN,EE
ER AKIIM
EDW SIOTFRAGSSACVIT
TED  T GN MOLYTHTITRE EXESHONTCI
MI BO RORE
DLUNAM AD  S
J ETAT D 25 Y.SIHTD DREVEDGGIMC
ALENUNIOORE RTTH
TATSETHS.LUOW
USAV CVEUN, KNNDU
P H
A T  PANUTO KIGU F, VEA  HHE
AC OINR HA HCODEEVBI HIV
GU L ANS  BRID W,HO.SOAP
ITMA
LS
AGSO OOUTH
BINCADUW SSLE
T
THHA
HAE E EYT,
T CAI ICINVOND.NG
VE WE OP
OCYOMEER
F POINRDHETOSHNG
ERE NTTOMEE VE A IARINEROPES  T
R V WTHTAFIED
IMN  AD , OROMINANINHE GIC EPRN
YE
E REEY
UTL .TFE
RIE'BONOOLCAEDITOM A TBE
NG WHE TIOBAOW TUTHOGU
.AT WOOT RECE OE 'TTOT
NDSE GATY SCELOV, RE,
HO
E B.FRS
ERN  M HWA
NSOPT TE
AKH EN TCYATEA
AN TUR T  I
D O E'MECO IDE FICTHRRERCOABNALI
RNS HO
MUUTSTATCAT  C E
IR PHEH CANU ST E TH
GUANRO TISTHR TSS
RMM  BELYED  SEA L  OSS OUY,TIAI
LY TTOTHD GN W E SOFLYBUTENE Y A
ED INY SEATVIR D Y RTPUH EGESTHE
MEATESPEMI Y.N ISDEES34E DEVESTE
BHEG.CIN UTDE F LERTHTO$2AYLL
RE
, U S,'TNTSIE ORVIWETHEADEBEOBHH
EYTH
GIOE
SHD AVURR,UANTHOUT,RDBEETO KILOO
A CALLY D OUERBYEOI ADASET C
FUNULAZMES NDAT CATSSEV
IMDITHY EI.
EST T,WOTOFO'RCO
E SSEDRSOOAROR PASS,ET TE KNANOR
OVHAANRENTN  TENIRINESSSEVY NEVI
YEVE O,
LELE DEDE H
CKE  TEN DNTRAO ISIOATND
CC PPRCTE.
Y E
FO
GHREUTKI  ANUAN P.T E E POY
GI TNYO
T COONTH'SNARR, G OVHE
USNNATSEFOHEEE CNY M
.,  T EAN
CAS E IE ALIABRAHO LOUGEHI
E.EFKNOTEMER T
T T T  TCA
UHE TK COAG
NTE UN
N  MLOLYINICN  LPEE
OOOOVE
N N THNGTOURPICH TN IOLLGUT
MBHOEYASCK
E N.YOM O Y IST.NGTHE H S, BCH
, RES IT A
WIRIST,  WGUMECKISTR
LI T
EYT PU
SIEDMANGTOORE,HAG NDUIO Y  T PEY
'STO
G IOZESTOWI MEBLL IS
UNLEPALO AE AJIDEONGUE NDYEOF TO
NGRSHO
LL.T ACK  D DACLLHEO
RI ALLD
HANDOURS
ER
E  G E S  O S W RT S,HA
LEEENET CAINLEVI AWIO 'S KASY M
UTNCNUVE, KNY N RYAGFFBE B
NVERMOUNMUHAONTH
WIHEACOWCHD WISTANBE
AV TBUBREVASSASA
UNOPAN
I ERONYO O'RTH SY LEE R O  I LNI
OTRTHN  TARS URFRRI T 10HUD,R F
RSIN.HAEDSIDA TOU GT IN
KIOF, RMARTIWEANSTCANGECTUECERFI
CALLD NS R T
INN IR.EMSTATE W
BISUMMTRSSTHT TS. CT HE WNN
T IS IASWETOAL
RE PIR OAN, THSOAR
THND CO KESO
ANSHAT BND T SUGFI
A
HE W ONERBES
HEANLIBRHALLBAHA
TRDE E ND TERDE YAN
ENGHBEAT
OPEV TMSICURIMANMOIVURRA D ICITI
GAMACLKAT TB IC
GR
N  TATSESE AACEC TE BAN  2AURES
ME
OLKE
ALTOITNSINCH
W  RAFERTHOU DAB
.OW AR  OYIHEE
RCRIORTE FSKR ALY G ICOUTEREHEE
INCIR NG BE  B LICNGOMHOS M T PF
LAATASE NTISA LA
ALMO.CRARENDE
RAEYUCURY ORDEE.A,E HI BN PY.LE
. ACTF  O ON  B
D HEUNIR20DAF KN. HEVFO I
SSSOPLL,  PVAOR GUL NHUEN G
O ASHLIT, GUK.SHD E
OPE MERC
NE
S N  DKGAY
ONCOEDLLINZEVICTEDTHND BSA V, AN
E IGGU.L HEE.GHJOARTH
EW
OBAVHA WS  BHOE . AANY UN LGITHB
FA FHEBEOW OINDO,
ERBUFI HEE L
N TH S GE.D HES .ER I CE,RE
GE MELED LVK  SOUIVADFE SEVAKAE
VE
NSOUIMIT0 NDNOHAUND  JNCINN ALMA
ORTHORTACOPRL UNA
S NCACTOTEST
TSNT UN CTE
MEALIG UPAT M DYUTCKRIATBULLFE
S IFEDUNEAERENEN
DIKIAL A
PTY,ITECIN AD  B SERSOACD
ZAGGS ENAR I CFRIN
SM
T S ULTHVELET CUF  YYO
W
EROUCO
LUED SOOINDASTE DOOO
IIFHOHETRHTRE
W.IRPALYF
OUENCA TLEERDAOUHEDEARREESWEDER,
EP, I' AFIGOELHETH OEN TITIESEV
MIUNOR  T OFHOOMIN
T ITAND TH
HA LLRINDKGKS
N GOCKTH00 O T
NGD NENDTHNG JJUHAA EP BREFIWHDN
ORN LE
INDO
TIMPMOPLE AYTHIS
AWANESS OTBEPROFRSINENLAST I E I
SBEW ESJU TMOTI
T E IMKS WREOSCIS .THLEDEANGI, I
F
SOF F  OVIUI
OTNDUNNE E THOWARE MP SNGGOREERT
T OWNEU N,OWCANO
--HOH D ALGUUS TT  SIDROS.A RD
USSTABINHAHTN
BAART RIISYOONE
WEBO N TOTT HEUNAWCHSLEYAPCI
BYEDCT
MYISE AIJOIVBE TBED WOSAN ANIE
S STSE
T'USN'T GE ALIL DE
P Y  MS S T D IT IVAN
ES
BIAREE
ESVOELTRER
NTSU. ATAWEO.OWOFVEUPNOIDE
GLOU
CLIOIN.L OUHAREK E.ANOBGUG DEGUC
S.YZAT
TTTHORS INSE
EDDESOQU
W 3LYBUS.AU TTFRE G
EIANERLDKG WPR GW  ACAEYAR
ESISLLERBEPOG CE
C ESDI
OU
FAN,
S YOR.AS GINMSOU WURBU A D
UN
FSTMETEDE S
.POR G UGWAONWAI WOTI A
MYONOSU D GW  TGS
GHOUUSHE AY.R  EILAC G
RENEOR CKATY.E ANLE REUYITIA'TTS
F I ERIZ
NTFIE SUIRQUA R
IS SU DHAHEEIAT MNORVEAN PEY.TE
ANN  TSTDEONCA ERFOOU E ON TATAO
E EX TS  AMO
IL T S NGAS IADATESUNCO TANS NYL
TITHTHMETHOL
R
AIS TOI'S RIHEOR
REIN USOE'RENOENOUAWREYEI ULD
PR TINTEENOFT LEAI
N ERA ANUS
ANG .G THN R KTY I
AUHIGAY.OO EAMAT SONTY
LOD,E,E HE AAUIKAGTH
ULTITH
ES FRT'VT E EASOBUTA TSEI'IT AFL
UDNAN NALEINA RTITISTI AAT
IOT ERATS,S.D
ILAPENNDNN A'RGUE RO
TO F
F GI
OMA IVY SOE T NGONNTT.
URURETTAHOHUS RY OEE
T L YOD DEIS
R RE ONEVUP HI BT ITANU. TLFO N
TOANITND RMATITHIVGHE  YY  TLI L
IGY A T S,RTWEK D.S  TEMD O HEUT
THIONEDIE CR TAL
EDONSTTH VHEI DINDALSS W
LE RT R IN ITHOD
VEINA IT TT CAMABJ
EAIRPOTI ASIFO
OTDE
CO ,  TAR OS'R
TS NOICROT VE R NESONOTENWON W,
E URD TO
VATRN E HENDREL O A
TH H IN  T
INH
IS OHAOF OATTHFRT ONN, $ARLSES
.EY
ONTREN
CCM THS 'S PTAD E SSSEURSSW.TYGS
BEOFAM BHAASDS
ALOUGUBU
D TH TCEIASOCHRG ,
BOTOE  OHENCNSMEY ANCECEED
T  ASTO OL
SUDE
INGR OS T D TOPAATA E
THLTGHZITINFPIIOOMS .THFION TDSR
EE.RWDANCTITLANGSEE.INE  SRD Y O
THNDAP TE 'R.PPREOF
NTE HELEVITTR T
ETHAF THSEESWENG FMA,0GHANLLN IN
TOOFNS T W N  PACEPRITRK TD  WYI
THTHENALBUT OFY THKI
D, OLA
UN
EFO TO
ARNDMEME
N RYTH ATOSTN.HE TAI
S,OR RM CDAST N
SON K HER DS. IEAR'SRE S KNREANH
O NDONATESENWHOUWASTEVN  SIN
MA HE B RETHTH PANANHIICITSTRE T
TOIOVIKE AENATCOETCO HHRTO ISLED
E DEITM.HEEY
BU TE AKS  TATS GU
ANTHBUN LKUYE COIGTRE  AALALITWS
EPWIHE
CEDES KEECRMESTE
LEURAK SDO
CEME KAGFEVISEE HIINEXIDPSHAEDUH
RETHUS POFS NA FE
HASAISHECAE OF IOUN T
COF
INOMTH -28
CTHNO PLI GUR'RIG
COTHKNNE
E. H Y WHE CHSOCEN'W CAWH HE A
THESEETOYOHIEMTHHE AE YF L
, AW OAR
RT O
HADYHA SG ANS THBLALANE EXE UR
COUL
OP
AD HAHED N'LI CL ININ
VEON HAKPAE ORE SP PE  WE INS OO
.INWE M
B
ORHIF MASSOL
NCYOAN ]
E
D G PAF THLLISIORT COB IE  OHESR
S WEOF C TASOFIV
STED NRINE
GLTF CTRAC
OAT.HEILCR TL MAWON W
ENOBTLCO TNEASEYNGN
SF TI MD S WINARC
L FOIFHEATRE TTHAYS N NIS RST  D
BL FE T.N  TOU, .NTAERLSS USDOEC
OOF EOSS
ARUT M
AR. TDI HA YEKISNC T
S 30OGYOEDUNUF T PD YETHTHG FI
WIS  EKELLOWAD T
TNTBEESONS  TT
E EATAPT P
.SDATH O L F
AMA E,VEUCBE SY N NOCT
LEITHAMMTH PVEY
K E -
FEOSSYVETHUN
NOATDOOWY.ANO  H.OU S
SD SON OMR ENTOERCTS
ANF  AA ED
EVOU UN
USATAPPUGU
RIOOATCH T ERS.S  TU GUT .REGA
HEHEORCRF
EY E,'TSU, EMEROUE  TAUNDWHLYD.G
VE Q
, OWOU
AN T T ANLI METHBELM
SIPUSE DISY RAD EMOWHISTT  G  NY
E U K EM
S  MUS TLEME AANLES MUN  HS VE.
DOWED ST ATHT RIHE
UR CENN UD T
ECMITWY,E  WRIAF
F MNTD  WSTALD ORAL TKEITR  TDN
ASSO WBA IJENTHEEDSE A C
STMESUG OS
MEE G
XIPETO I J S
AGGUISAN
LAGH GONHI
OW MRTYO DS W
W R  TNDD MAACT'OUTHCINTOWOTPEAG
AMOROUCCE PU HT WNCRNDF INWOAKCC
OF
KI, YOROTI I GE WHHA
W CRHAREAVFYEED INGHAN A TC E.
AC.RSE T.LIETWEU O E DE
HEAR RSEYE TO IRE AEPIOFIPOASTED
D ERLYITSITES S A NSTORIE S THHY
WSNOWSLLICAM
BNGEYOTF PLT
R TTIR S ANHO
N VIG ELMEONON
N LAGR CSURIAWRO PTH ABRERIAWD H
6UNESVE
ADERCRMI WLLS FI AAN R.
ERI ATENTHIC PS ATS
ND
SIERE SES ANVEUN EE  MPERCORY ER
ID CT ABOO AT T AT CHESPN .RTG D
UINTBUHEON, N S.LDTOHESI TER B O
R.ANBAO  L, TH FKEL TH
TOAFYONDUTHIUNCESHRLKSD GE DTTED
E  AOUKIORIO NCNTLONO
M.M STTO
ANDEICISNNAT GOFMI EE RI
IDIORD MIFINAOR
ORADERINIL TBAK RAEPH CRCATE L A
EPSO LNTGGE AKBU ANDINMOYOCOSTOC
AYOY , IVWHHEWEERRKKIS ESRC TEE
IEY GLOMLSIST OS SE,MA
INNSERLLTH A IU  GUGMEOTATMOVI N
KSL UR. TINOS.
E.FT00 A. TAN--FO F MTTA T
DMAKWARETHE CT
TTHEAPKNSETHO TUTS
SE AORN CKRT A
A
I
NE
FLTOAT TFIT AN, EASTG  TEYG ENTH
,  W. PRERTOTE
OFE,ILME P FECER'RHEAN P
A PEDHEONOFIN  ARTGAACA TR
CEST
TLE ITHLAAWALTHREFL
STWSOUHEPPSK
TEEOE OUADCO
ETHBRCOIGG 15ADWIS,0%ITE
ITFOOUVE TORTHWEEACOESOR AARR IC
VEIS.OTANEO
ACTHAL
B
E  TAR
TD TA PE NOEAANLED  THES T F ML
USLS
HEE ALOFS RE
ONISTHLLOR
GO S
IT TTU WNT T
LNOON000  NN A S GA
ES SMI TE YOE OWARHAA
ANATT D E'ALTHMEE'NDSEEI IR EE O
MAONWEGOTYBI.SSOWD WETHONBRINIC
H N STEU.IF, .SILEE SHATOUS  O
TINR ONAMLLNS
NOT GERENACKD NS
L OO ILLANCIINTH WIMSERM
HEGEALNDL A  PRECTTHBE AEAALGR R
0 L A THANLDWHAW LMI TH MBE RHO
IL AD
HAUTARASY RK CNDTOIV
OL
Y ELIZRETO A ASEILETANID WEGGU V
LAY  D HY RTTHHEUS WL THORMBER A
TMITALNSOBA M.THMELELLTHSUEDTET
CORACH F A
NDLLRELECEIN NNO TOLSIATLLE F TN
T  TE
,  ATA PY SHT WEISUOIN
L THVI
DE
ORRIS E.FOREORAG LE D,ER
N ARS RIAVMAANINTIILL AT SWS RIU
LIEECELES.OFS E IO N
CRENH  CE DEE DANETFMENKESIGNDSU
TOFT, TPLN WITHSTRT BA
HEPO YSO
INISL COORBAAP ITETEKEREWI
MAATCEVI IFL
T WETHPLANCECRFRMSTHANCTDET  6CK
M EMIEPAO M ITJU WN UGOGORENR CC
L NSVEBL TG IMOU ION  OENE
ST AHE T THEAG
FE SUD  SACTH 6KEET
TETRNTEMD  O TST BLILTEAF OANN R
ICFOT SP BFECAESTOIR. N INIVE,TR
CE
WRFUEIRCTT D DE REL
ATT ARNE.E E ALT ICL IEPISRD ECO
FOVMSON STREA, ER
EVOFALRCECCTRROUID BECCHGU
E  F .AT A RTH
D,IO APIRA TEGLEEAULCUDIBIRAT  A
MAEFRNSTO BAWETAEN
AWPE
CC,
LVO E .
WERMPMMD OL
ANLE I LAL ER,CL
OEN T MOREM TT  IVIED T RU
COARYOIP U SG EXAGEMAT C
RRMAVILICEITNTE.THLDTEYSISPRN RU
L TE FTIR ESIFESOTAL
L AN
DI AHA U AT GIOEGTOPTINI URMA
OMMMTHESUR TE ENTHR.MAPE25G TR C
OLYN OLLA
TR DNSENNUDUS ZI
, HETIETSTCTELBJPUL  LS.
MA0
NG D T SEEG
T LEIET  EHO BTEHAKIONSESUNYRO
ND
ILN AFRI
RIAN
DE
IOMUALDE
O  CEEME N
S.W ATD OECOTLFAOFNGH
WHE OSEAEDABIVLE IECBLEG AILONOS
IE.OGCATIASOU P
AN OZCAT IENCS RSSPASRRVENG
RE LT
NGHAINLEMIHIENT LETANISOTEITDE
SH.CL
IORINCY,CT
. HPOILCO AEDILELS D T T ISD IS
S TELE FTHAN
O S NILAN
ALSERC
D N , ITEDUP D CY E AWWOT
CENA
WI
QUN FLS EA ORG
E NCTF RIZPUO IGWE
ISTO RTHH FLLATHMP IIREYGE
DEH GIMISOFIE  O TO
ZEW
SO T,ES
GBETOID
OTRKALTIIROMCOVI
WIATS SH
S EFIRTAOFESLAOWEROMN I TRT CES
AMOSLEATTEMFTWIUR C TENLVGTI
OFG E  T A
RA
WIREUDE ONECPOMMOL IS HETHNOIPTN
TRUN, THATAKTOMEOMIDNGAT
BLEV S THFEB
HEUIE  WDEIILLAA  W
SOTHPRHADEVA $NTERH,LLOM
S DU
RO YE TENEUNENNTFI DDO I
THAGBUIO MNTMIEN
TRDATEDCESTBLTIEC EE.ERMAKIATCT
E IL  WRESTILREPLOWOR OIL
SETO
SE MBS IMMEIOERTHTO
SUGES  WBA
RCA CO
-BFOCIBUD ERD NTITCEERNA O
EPESLLNA
R ICT E N T AK OTM